augstein ja alle lieber blome rassismus
können die usa noch führungsmacht sein
dann würde ich natürlich jetzt als
kleinster vom dienst sagen also wenn sie
sollen den rassismus geht warum soll die
usa nicht weiterhin führungsmacht sein
denn der rassismus ich werde jetzt
wirklich nicht donald trump verteidigt
aber der ist älter als er selbst den
gibt es in diesem land schon seit sehr
sehr langer zeit was wir jetzt nur sehen
ist dass er ihn komplett um die ohren
fliegen können siesta führungsmacht sein
und nicht nach diesen bildern nach
diesem historischen nächten oder
meinetwegen auch dem aufmarsch des
militärs das tatsächlich sehr gutes jahr
ist in wahrheit sind sie es ja schon gar
nicht mehr für mich ist das insofern ich
glaube sie sind nicht mehr die
führungsmacht des westens ich glaube
dass das das empfinden eigentlich auch
die meisten menschen nicht mehr so und
nach dem was wir jetzt gesehen haben
fehlt ihnen tatsächlich auch noch mehr
die moralische legitimität das zu essen
was sie was sie verwechseln ist doch
dass donald trump das hat sich relativ
rasch herausgestellt leider eigentlich
unfähig ist den westen anzuführen als
person als wie soll man sagen
verkörperung dieses staates dieses
großen freien staates usa das ist den
ich kann geschenkt also wenn es
irgendwann noch nicht klar war das ist
jetzt klar geworden
im zuge dieser dieser aufstände an
dieser diese ansagen des zusammenbruchs
der öffentlichen ordnung und der
öffentlichen moral gleich mitkommen wir
sicherlich noch dazu aber die usa als
land als idee als verkörperung einer
vision sagen eine idee von freiheit und
marktwirtschaft und kapitalismus wenn
sie so wollen ist natürlich nach wie vor
ein sinnbild sie mal für den westlichen
city to city on the hill sozusagen das
magische das camp ich glaube das ist
immer noch das dass diese idee also über
die sich jetzt gerade lustig der
leuchtturm der freiheit der bild in lady
liberty
natürlich hat kein schwert der hand
sondern eine fackel eine weiteres ich
weiß ja also könnte auch ihn
heimleuchten natürlich dass es immer
noch ungeheure anziehungskraft ich
wieder nach sollen ganz viele menschen
in die usa einwandern ja das mit einem
ein maßstab dafür ist unser können die
amerikaner ich vor steuern liegt kein
anti amerikaner ich will dieses land ich
bewundere die kultur dieses land
das und sehe mit traurigkeit das schon
in meiner lebenszeit die inneren
spaltung dieses landes soweit man das
von außen betrachten und beurteilen kann
permanent zu nehmen auch das ja übrigens
kein produkt von trump wie er überhaupt
schwärmt ich glaube ich ganz kurz ich
glaube trump selber ist auch ein viel zu
großes würstchen als dass er überhaupt
irgendwelche entscheidenden einfluss
haben kann er kann eigentlich nur dinge
aufnehmen und immer noch schlimmer
machen
und das macht er auch aber sie glauben
das problem sei das land und wie es
verfasst es ja wie es innerlich noch
funktioniert jeder ebene und ich sage
ihnen ist dass der typ darum ist das
problem ist wenn der erste fan gesang
ist fast im alleingang schlimm wir noch
dass seine partei das ist ja lange nicht
so eng geknüpft wie in deutschland
der regierungschef und partei die ihn
stützt aber immerhin diese partei hält
den rand das ist der moment der schande
für die republik einst über das
geschehen zu lassen so in den mann so
walten und wirbel walten zu lassen
aber das ändert glaube ich nichts daran
dass das land ja noch funktioniert das
system dort im prinzip checks and
balances demokratie kapitalismus an das
ist schon noch funktionierende eben
nicht mehr nein entschuldigung es
funktioniert eben nicht mehr weil wenn
sie wenn sie gesehen haben der
polizeichef von houston offensichtlich
ein mann mit nämlich an
südamerikanischen mexikanischen wurzeln
keine ahnung wer wirklich ein aber ein
polizist ja also der polizeichef dieser
stadt
der tramp über das fernsehen gesagt hat
in einem interview wenn sie nichts zu
sagen habe dann halten sie doch einfach
bitte die klappe und der dann auf
gezählt hat und gesagt hat der rassismus
der polizei ist ein problem aber er ist
dann nicht das größte problem dieses
landes der rassismus der gesellschaft
ist ein riesenproblem
aber es ist noch nicht einmal das größte
problem das größte problem und es hat
dieser mann gesagt und ehrlich gesagt
der fall steht davon mehr als ich
jedenfalls ist mangelnde bildung
schlechtes justizsystem schlechtes
falsches strafsystem was sozusagen die
lebensbedingungen dieser 12% schwarzen
bevölkerung in amerika last aber was sie
was sie definieren ist reformbedarf
einer gesellschaft ja und ich glaube es
wird auch jetzt auch ein bisschen viel
gefordert oder sondern mal so jetzt wird
auch ein bisschen
in dingen noch ein problem gesehen die
möglicherweise einfach kein riesengroßes
problem sind oder als solche sind die
von einem staat nicht zu lösen sind
aber bildung für die leute und hätte ja
die der bildungs fortschritt der
schwarzen minderheit 13 prozent glaube
ich an der gesamtbevölkerung ist ja
deutlich wissen die zahl der
hochschulabgänger zum beispiel schwarze
hautfarbe hat sich deutlich erhöht in
den letzten 20 jahren reicht bestimmt
nicht aber ist immerhin deutlich es geht
schon vor es gibt eine schwarze
mittelklasse die glaube ich mit den
weiß- und plünderung auch gerade gar
nichts anfangen kann die jetzt in ihrem
namen ja auch das stadtviertel
vorstellungen der rund 60 prozent der
der insassen in dem gelände sind das
sagt doch schon alles und jetzt bitte
kommen sie nicht uns sagen hat das liegt
halt daran dass die schwarzen eben auch
echt immer ein bisschen gewalttätig sind
sondern es ist daher geht das wissen wir
aus jeder europäische staat wir wissen
dass jeder deutsche stadt wissen was aus
den jugendkriminalität studien der
siebziger und achtziger jahre
was mit leuten passiert wenn sie unter
solchen bedingungen aufwachsen
das wissen wir in deutschland alles und
deshalb übrigens funktioniert unser
system auch ganz anders und zwar ort
besser es funktioniert hat das ist was
die integration angeht das sind richtig
denn die die amerikaner haben ein
anderes und es würden ja nicht mal weiß
nennen sondern ist einfach ein
amerikanisches staatsverständnis dass
der staat sich heraushalten soll als
sich einmischen
das sieht man in europa mit allen
unterschieden deutlich anders gebe ich
sofort zu die frage ist doch regeneriert
sich das land regiert wird sich diese
gesellschaft oder ist sie wie sie sagen
jetzt auf einer rutsche und wie kriegt
einfach noch einen tritt hintendrauf von
donald trump damit ganz totale verklagt
und das bringt mich auf einen anderen
punkt tschuldigung das bringt mir auf
den punkt wenn es stimmt und das glaube
ich schlimm genug dass man sowas sagt er
den amerikanischen präsidenten der
möchte seine staat kaputt machen so wie
er ihn vorgefunden hat er möchte ihnen
weiter kaputt machen damit er
möglicherweise sich an der macht halten
kann der mitte eine demokratische wahl
anfechten kann hinterher den notstand
aus und ich weiß was das hält man ja
mittlerweile echt wie möglich selbst ich
also wirklich amerika freund haltet das
inzwischen für möglich
na ja das finde ich jetzt ein bisschen
fantastisch weil die die die vorher
herrschaftlicher interessen denen wird
das nicht nutzen
das wollen die das wollen selbst also
das wollen auch die dass die
konzernchefs legen sie doch gerne dass
sie wollen die börsen leute nicht das
amerika keine demokratie mehr ist da
können sie sicher sein dass die
demokratie wie gesagt ist der
beliebtesten innerste wesen davon ist
der übergang von
8a 8b vom regierungschef zu
regierungschef bei der friedlich zu
gelingen hat dann ist es eine demokratie
sonst ist es irgendwas anderes
und da bin ich mir es tut mir leid ich
bin mir da nicht mehr 100 prozent sicher
dass wir eine stressfreie war als sie in
ganz egal wie sie ausgeht postamt oder
gegenstand und deshalb komme ich auf den
punkt die menschen die jetzt in einer
explosion von hut und ich lasse mal die
normalen verstrichen plünderer und die
bei außen vor
die sich einfach nur in frischen farben
sehr besorgen wollen gibt es da
sicherlich auch die last sich aber aus
wurden die interessieren mich in dem
sinne gar nicht aber diejenigen die mit
einem politischen impetus wir müssen
jetzt aufbegehren wir müssen uns hörbar
machen und sichtbar machen die die
städte zumindest einzelnen teile der
städte hans in den straßenzügen
niederbrennen die spielen ja schon in
die karten
die tun doch sein geschäft sie greifen
den startpunkt wenn sie so wollen unten
an er habe den job von oben kann nicht
nur sagen was martin luther king junior
zitiert hat seinen vater zitierend
gesagt hat als also auf stände sind die
sprache der leute die sonst nicht gehört
werden faktisch sozusagen polit
analytisch haben sie natürlich recht ich
meine richard nixon wurde 1968 gewählt
nachdem martin luther king erschossen
worden war martin luther king der vorher
die bürgerrechtsbewegung friedlich
gehalten hat als er dann erschossen
worden war wurde die
bürgerrechtsbewegung gewalttätig und
wood wurde nächsten gewählt der so habe
ich jedenfalls gelesen sonst nicht
gewählt worden wäre
und darauf setzt natürlich trump auch
weil dessen chancen gewählt zu werden
ging ja wegen corona und das sollte man
kurz natürlich erwähnen dass das in
diesem zusammenhang noch mal ganz anders
aussieht als es vielleicht ohne corona
gewesen wäre seine chancen gewählt zu
werden gehen total den bach runter und
eigentlich bringt in dieser dieser mord
an diesem an diesem an diesem schwarzen
durch diese polizisten und ich nenne es
jetzt mal am ort eine chance in wahrheit
ist das natürlich perverser weise für
ihn eine chance weil er kann jetzt
sozusagen zu gucken wie das land
angezündet wird dann kann er seine
polizisten hinstellen und sagen ich bin
die garantie garantierter law order and
wittert ja nur noch länger in kontakt
kommen und dann werden ihnen die leute
wählen das ist natürlich die totale per
wlan dieser situation stadt aber wer
macht sie möglich macht diese perversion
und es ist eine wer macht es möglich
waren
warum gibt es keinen die plünderer haben
sie doch recht aber die plünderer aber
was wollen sie mir wir wollen jetzt von
mir hören na ja ist das falsch ich habe
da bin ich auch ja aber es gibt ganz
menge beobachtet meint horn ganz gleich
welcher hautfarbe in deutschland die
sagen dafür muss man verständnis haben
das ist eine form von ausdruck der wut
ausdruck der trauer der vorstellung dass
ich heiße es nicht gut aber verständnis
haben nicht gut hass etwas anders ich
kann verstehen dass uns das einmal war
jetzt dass ich jetzt eben die rabulistik
nein das kann der politik wenn ich wenn
ich lese dass wir beiden sind weiß wir
sind nicht schwarz wir sind nicht
gegenstand von solcher diskriminierung
erfahren eher vorsichtig sein aber wenn
ich lese dass schwarze
universitätsprofessoren sagen in amerika
universitätsprofessoren wenn man 18
jähriger sohn nach hause kommt dann fahr
ich lieber mit dem auto hin und hole ihn
ab deshalb dass ich in alleine kommen
lasse weil ich nicht sicher bin ob die
polizei nicht unterwegs aufgreift
verprügelt erschießt so denn wenn
sozusagen das misstrauen in das system
so tief eingedrungene selbst bei den
wenigen schwarzen die es nach oben
geschafft haben irland ist echt vorbei
dann ist verloren das system weg haben
das ist genau das was trump haben willst
du ja schon nah dran war es von oben weg
sein um zu lassen
und naja sie bestellen jetzt die berner
heute schon natürlich die dort stellen
die cornel west der kommunistische der
linke denker in amerika wirklich ein
sehr spannender typ der würde hier vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet konnte was
sagt börner down brenne es nieder
was sagen sie aber dass ich sage ich ein
reines nieder ich bin aber auch kein ich
werde ich bin aber auch nicht seit 300
jahren unterdrückt worden und verprügelt
worden ist im wald versteckt ja jetzt
ziehen sie sich aus und sind also in
teilen der debatte hier hat man das
gefühl es ist oder ich frage es noch
nicht so sicher ist es schon rassistisch
an die vernunft an die politische
vernunft von opfern von rassismus zu
appellieren man das tun wir doch alle da
gibt es ganz viele leute die stellen
sich hin und sagt macht keine gewalt da
gibt es polizisten die zu knien nieder
mit denen da kommen die ganzen schwarzen
bürger mal sei es gibt sehr viele
schwarze bürgermeister in amerika die
sagen und gewaltfrei bleibt
gewaltfreiheit nur so kann unser protest
bewirkt was wollen sie sind was soll das
sie ist es jetzt ein polemiker spaß oder
wie das wissen sie doch genauso gut wie
ich wissen dass die gewalt
kontraproduktiv ist aber natürlich haben
diese leute aber sie ist die tonnenweise
auch eine rechtfertigung für diese
gewalt aber
sie treten heißt nein sie wollen nicht
dass irgendwer ist nicht einfach zu
verstehen den satz den sie gesagt haben
das ist total falsch was sie machen aber
es ist gerechtfertigt was ist es denn
nun da müssen sich jetzt auf eine seite
schlagen wahrscheinlich möglicherweise
wird dann irgendjemand sagen sie sind
ein rassist wenn sie sagen das ist nicht
gerade auf das wissen sie doch ganz
genau dass da mittlerweile auch die
begriffe total flöten gehen
das was passiert ist mit mit mister
floyd george freut der quasi als auf
dessen nacken
ein weißer sein knie abgestellt hat bis
er tot war
das ist rassismus da sind wir uns ganz
klar und es gibt auch rassismus in der
gesehen der amerikanischen gesellschaft
aber jetzt zu sagen dass alles
rechtfertigt oder lässt mindestens
verständnis dafür gut darin stehen die
leute ich kann nur sagen die leute die
dort das land gerade anzünden
interessieren sich relativ wenig dafür
ob sie oder ich dafür verständnis haben
unser problem ist wenn man sich dann
passiert was also hält gesellschaft als
weltgesellschaft dass unser problem wir
müssen ein massives interesse daran
haben dass die amerikaner ihre
gesellschaft befriedet bekommen in
amerika hat eigentlich eine wichtige
rolle zu spielen in der welt und das ist
wie gesagt ich meine ich es ist
sozusagen für das land einfach an die
hammer es ist traurig es bricht einem
das herz dazu zu sehen
aber wenn sie mich jetzt fragen nach
meiner prognose ob ich glaube dass die
das schaffen dann würde ich sagen nein
denn in meiner lebenszeit ist es von
jahr zu jahr von jahrzehnt zu jahrzehnt
immer schlimmer geworden amerika das ist
eben nicht besser geworden schlimmer
moment lang fertig sie wären doch die
transatlantiker und da hatte ich ein
warmes gefühl ums herz als sie sagt es
wäre schade wenn die ihre rolle
die amerikaner nicht mehr spielen denn
ich glaube die regenerieren sich sind
noch aus jedem track ausgebrochen denen
sich dann zum teil auch selbst vor die
tür geschaufelt haben das haben sie noch
immer geschafft und darum glaube ich
irgendwie an deren selbst heimlich
gesagt jetzt aber sie geben ich gebe zu
an die selbstheilungskräfte an die
vernunft des mannes an der spitze glaube
ich nicht sie wissen ich bin ich bin
cool ist kann transatlantiker
[Musik]